everybody's talking about gold these
days and I wish I had some to show you
but I don't own any so sorry the thing
about gold is it is a very important
part of our financial system when we're
looking at the expectation of inflation
because even though inflation can mean
that the value of currencies go down
gold is supposed to hold its value and
that's because people will always accept
gold in trade for other things so we
hope gold has intrinsic value gold is
nice to look at and it's useful in a lot
of commercial products but it's also
accepted and has been symbolically for
hundreds of years as a medium of
exchange as a unit of account and as a
store of value there could have been
another focal point perhaps it could
have been quartz quartz would have been
seen as a great store of value but
traditionally quartz doesn't have that
role even though like gold there's
probably a limited supply of quartz
crystals in the world gold is where it's
act and everybody sort of accepts gold
that's what makes it valuable the
problem is if we were to base our
monetary system on gold that some people
like Ron Paul had proposed we would have
a fixed amount of gold equal to one
dollar and every time we wanted to issue
more currency we would have to make sure
that we had that much more gold in our
treasury what happens then though think
about what would happen if somebody
discovered a huge amount of new gold
that we didn't know about in the world
all of a sudden the supply of gold would
be much higher and that would probably
mean that the price of gold would go
down in world markets but that would
have a profound effect on our own
currency too because each of our dollars
would now be worth less through no fault
of our own so we would have a devalued
currency simply as a result of this
discovery of gold that's not something
that we want to mess around with because
it means that other people and other
events can control our monetary policy
which is one of our most basic tools for
affecting our economy and our economic
cycle so if you want to use gold as part
of our monetary system you have to think
very hard about the fluctuations that
we'd be exposing ourselves to
you